thanks everybody
and thanks for that introduction
um yeah so
you may have seen in the
paper in the description of what i'm
going to talk about i'm going to talk a
bit about
my interest recently in how games can
address climate change um and it may you
know this is pretty new i'm going to say
it's something i have not been working
on excessively until really recently
and i want to talk about kind of how i
got to thinking about this
and why and um to do that i'll i'll
introduce a little bit more of work that
i've done up until this point
and maybe try to pull it all together
uh so and by the way this is kind of a
you know i'm coming out of presentation
hibernation of a sort i'm sure
many are right now i i looked back and i
probably haven't talked in front of a
you know a not an audience that wasn't
my own students for like two years
um so yeah that's gonna be fun
and um so much has changed obviously in
that time it has not been an easy time
since uh then
and uh in fact it you know for a lot of
people reevaluating what they do i count
myself among them i uh
you know certain
realities of the world really started to
sink in and uh made me sort of think
about like christina told me earlier
like it's all hands on deck what can i
do with what i've got to give to the
world
and so this is maybe you know my first
steps toward toward that
um
so what about this word exuberant does
anyone have an idea of not necessarily
the definition but other words that it
other thoughts that that it conjures up
for you any any thoughts
enthusiastic enthusiastic i have that
one yes exactly yeah
um another one that people come up with
often is rambunctious
um
any other thoughts
energetic energetic absolutely it like
expresses a sense of
energy in the world going and doing
things
um maybe lively
um
and even could be things kind of like
trickster trickstery playful
flourishing like when applied to nature
it often means like everything's just
kind of growing and
without control
and it's a word that's been used
somewhat frequently recently in writings
about what we can do regarding
the environment there's a book called
mobilizing the green imagination an
exuberant manifesto by anthony weston
and also the word rambunctious
such as
rambunctious games a manifesto for
environmental game design which is by
elinda chang
so it's a kind of thought that's been on
people's minds uh
and it to me it it implies so much
playfulness and how we bring
kind of this extra excitement and energy
to to what we do
and for me right now i really need that
i think that's why i was attracted to it
i've been you know it's been a really
tough and depressing time and having
that extra enthusiasm and this feeling
of kind of playful
misbehavior almost
feels really good to me and it's
something that i think resonates a lot
with my work so that's that's why i ram
exuberant
um so i promised i would give you a look
at what i have done up to this point
um so i want to start off with with an
event called gamma which originally
stood for game art montreal
that i
curated along with my collective
kokoromi at the time which was we
started around 2006
and there's four of us in the group or
kind of basically like a band but
instead of making music we're making
video games and these events that would
inspire people to
make indie games and bring them into a
social space and what you see here are
some images from a few different
editions we did four different editions
each one focusing on a slightly
different interface technology so
one was using music as a line in to
create content in the game that you
would interact with
and you see here
one of the bands that was playing that
event so the music that band is playing
is actually generating the creatures on
the screen behind it by taking the
different um
like low medium and high pitched notes
and creating creatures at different
creatures out of those
another
version we did gamma 3d which was right
around the time when a lot of
companies were trying to promote 3d
television as a thing you'd want and we
were trying to understand why that made
any sense at all and we went ahead and
and uh decided to
make a challenge about how could you
make games that were actually
stereoscopic but instead of going with
the sort of high-tech
things that that the companies were
trying to sell we went really lo-fi and
went to the what's called anaglyphic
stereo stereoscopy with the red cyan uh
glasses and tried to see what people
could do with that and the answer was
quite a lot
um but how could you really make it
matter in the inter in in the
interaction rather than just a
superficial oh that dinosaur looks
really gigantic like so
one of the games um was like a maze game
but it used colors that could only be
seen if you're wearing the glasses so if
you weren't wearing them it just looked
like almost like a mondrian just like a
wall of colored squares
worked really well
and the last one we did was a gamma 4
one button games um you know controls
for games are getting more and more and
more complex and i'm sure uh most of you
have played games that like if you
haven't been playing them like since the
series started and you tried to jump in
at the end
there's just so many
uh you know commands and uh
different conditional controls that you
have to learn for these things and we
were trying to look at what could you do
with just the very bare minimum on off
one button
interaction and how could you make that
exciting for people and the game that is
on the screen here was called brutally
unfair tactics totally okay now
otherwise known as button
and the idea
was that uh there are four buttons so
it's a four player multiplayer game and
uh
each time a command would come on screen
it would be something like this one
first player whose button is held for
seven seconds wins and you you had to be
standing back from these these buttons
and then just sort of make a mad dash
for it and try to see if you can hold
your button for the longest while
preventing anyone else from holding
theirs and as you can see from the
picture that is so blurry that you can't
even tell what's happening it was it was
quite a scramble um really really cool
game that was you know meeting that
challenge of it's only got one button
for each player but what can you do well
it's it's
it was pretty genius
um so we held these events uh roughly
one every year or every other year for
like seven or eight years and uh kind of
built up a culture
of exposing um experimental games in uh
more like a nightclub setting so people
with drinks or that that people meeting
each other and just the social
interaction you would get out of that
was really interesting because people
would not necessarily know how a game
worked but somebody next to them had
just played it and they would teach it
to them we made sure like that all the
games that showed in that were simple
enough that that you could get it
without having to go through a tutorial
or anything like that so it was really
games designed around this exact
cultural situation
um
okay and uh mentioned in the bio was
this particular piece which is called
the oh my bod app
started off
as an app called body heat and then got
purchased by the company that makes the
hardware which is a
a vibrator a sexual you know toy that is
um driven by a musical beat so um you
just turn plug it in to say like you're
at the time ipod and it would generate
vibrations based on uh the rhythm uh and
the different frequencies of the music
and i thought that was really
interesting i was like why can't i just
control it directly instead of using a
piece of existing music
well right around that time is when um
the you know the ipod touch came out
which was like the precursor touch
screen device to the iphone
and i was like okay perfect let's just
make an app that actually uh
controls the the vibrational patterns
and so it essentially took a multi-touch
input and translated that into
a sound wave that would directly uh
control the the vibrator um and the
company that made the vibrator actually
liked it enough that they're like yeah
we want this and so they bought it from
me and so now it's branded the oh my bot
app though the version i worked on is
like many generations ago so i think it
doesn't doesn't look the same anymore
um
and uh the
there's a lot of things i've done in a
physical space making physical space
playful
um
i call it here you know built
environment it's not only architecture
but it usually is inside an
architectural building
so
in 2012 i and two colleagues lynn hughes
and cindy parimba
curated an exhibition in a building in
paris called the gate lyrique and it's
full of all these uh it was built with
many different uh
ways to interface technologically like
text streams running and and uh you know
not just internet everywhere but but
really
the capability of doing uh projections
and things that all interconnected and
lots of different exhibition space
and we
curated different artists from around
the world who are doing interesting
things with games to create
installations that specifically took
advantage of the space that they were
assigned to and the one that you see
here in the background is called kit
operet it's by a group daily to le jour
and
in that one it was it was literally an
opera mini opera and operette
and the background music was playing in
a loop but it didn't have any vocals and
if you wanted to hear the vocals you
would need to
um use these different uh pieces of of
props basically opera props that were in
the room and so you see here are these
umbrellas which were on a on a kind of
string and you had to
twirl the umbrella to get a duet going
between two different characters
it was really really quite delightful um
and then other pieces you see here one
was called the building is by hide and
seek
in the middle uh there's um
a piece called ninja shadow warrior by
cajo abe
uh and the last one is called
interference it's uh
uh
eric zimmerman and his partner natalie
um so
this was like a really interesting way
to just take the physical space and make
it into something that no one had seen
before and really
used to great as much possible advantage
the the technology that was built into
the site but i think the important thing
i learned actually from this experience
is um the
importance of the people that were
working in this site
it wasn't really the kind of thing where
you could just set up this tech and walk
away and also people didn't really that
came to visit didn't really know what
was going on and we we gave them some
some guides but it was you know
something that they'd never experienced
before it was a little bit mysterious
and so when we uh created the exhibit we
uh did a um
training session with the people that
would normally be considered like the
museum guards you know um because they
were the ones who were enlivening the
space if someone came by themselves and
didn't have another person to play a
particular game with those people would
step in or they would help explain what
was going on but they would also be kind
of like actors in the mysterious role of
of
the building and it's and it's um
in one room there was actually like the
kind of the building's heart which was
like if you
um
if you did enough of these different uh
small installations you get access to
the secret room and and it was really
important that the the people who worked
there were helping
helping people along in their quest to
get to the building's heart so it was
really
important to like involve those people
not only um informationally but kind of
emotionally to want to play with with
visitors and make that a good experience
for those folks who came to to see it
um yeah mentioned previously the uh
super hypercube this is the the vr
version of super hypercube the first
version was actually using those red
cyan glasses so it was mostly black and
white
but when the
uh you know that last wave of um most
recent wave that we're still kind of in
of a vr development camera was coming
around so maybe you know mid
20 teens
um we
thought about well you know people have
been asking us to make super hypercube
available
uh commercially up until now it was only
something you could show at say a party
or
an exhibition
could we think about what we would do
with it if we did have
a full color and and we had it like
mounted on your head and
uh so we just kind of went to this like
retro futuristic dream of what was what
did people think the internet was gonna
be or uh before it existed so around
like the i guess
late 80s early 90s vision of of um you
know neon everywhere and we just kind of
like went hard and and went ahead and
just made that world and so um the
gameplay here is that uh you are zooming
through space kind of behind that
that green thing we call it the cluster
of cubes
and you're zooming forward and trying to
um fit into the wall which you can kind
of see it's very faint in the background
actually in this image i didn't think
about how faint the the wall is but the
the wall has like a two-dimensional
projection of one side of that cube of
that cluster of cubes and you're trying
to while you're zooming forward and it's
getting faster and faster you're trying
to rotate your the cluster so that you
get it so that you've got exactly the
right projection and you go through the
the hole in the right way and then the
other
um cubes will fall off so um there was a
japanese game show that a lot of people
know it was like human tetris if that is
familiar to anyone
where people would have to like uh the
wall was coming toward them and they'd
have to like do something like this and
try to make it so that they didn't get
thrown into a into a
pond of water or
similar and it was taking
that experience and applying it to this
uh virtual space
and the important thing for us there is
that the controls were very simple
you're really just rotating this cube
but the camera is of course controlled
by where your head is so you to be able
to see what your cube looks like and to
see
what the um
the hole in the wall looks like you'd
really have to put your body into it and
lean around and and it really meant
something it wasn't just oh i'm i'm
fixed in in space and i have like a 360
movie around me it really was very
physical and
that was important to us that we were
using proprioception as a way to learn
what we needed to know to be successful
in that puzzle
a full a full-body interaction really
important
a project i did a few years back chair
jam with a group of students at the
entertainment technology center where i
teach
was a an effort to
really
look at assistive technology not only as
a functional thing but also
as a more generative or expressive
medium
working uh with artist teresa devine we
put together and she teaches at asu um
we put together um a game jam
essentially where we brought together
uh
people from the pittsburgh community and
people from carnegie mellon and
actually held that
with patrick carrington's lab and in the
hci department
at cmu
and
the we put everyone in small teams and
their job was to work together with the
other folks on the team
some of whom were using wheelchairs and
some were not to figure out how they can
make something that uses the particular
capabilities of that specific chair
because not everyone is is the same
right they have different um
different affordances um and make those
into some kind of playful experience we
didn't require it to be like a game with
points or any anything like that it was
it was some of them were more
expressive like artistic like attaching
paint brushes and putting paper on the
floor and then using the chair to create
artwork
another one was kind of and i think the
team
i'm trying to remember if the team here
was the one i'm thinking of but one of
the teams did a kind of laser tag game
where
the people that were um
there were
there were different kind of like armor
that you were attaching um and
uh people would also have lasers that
were pointing outward from either their
chair or their body
and uh there were different attachments
you could use depending on whether you
were in a chair or you're on your feet
and it was an attempt to try to um
get everyone playing in the same space
because the laser could uh you know
angle at a certain way to hit a receptor
on the other person so that's that was
their solution to that particular
challenge
another
big strand of my
research and creative practice
is
i'm calling it here chemical senses
and i think mostly people would
associate that with smell
it could also mean food you know eating
is also chemicals
but in this in this particular
realm i've primarily worked with smell
and what do i mean by that i mean like
literally how do you use your sense of
smell in a digital uh experience and or
any kind of game really they didn't have
to be
especially when i'm teaching usually i'm
not using digital technology to design
games but in this case
wanting to look at how to use
your sense of smell as a way to play a
game and not as a kind of
uh just scene setting things oh you're
running through a field and you smell
flowers or uh you're in a restaurant you
smell food like there's some
different ways to use smell in in
making an experience more rich but what
i was interested in in looking at and in
my interactive
career is how are these things actually
used as part of gameplay meaningfully so
um in the case of this particular game
it's called guilty smells
um
you're playing this sniffing dog and
what you're trying to do is and it's a
very it's a satirical critical game so
um
be assured
it's it's done with a mind toward uh the
critique of the culture that it is
representing not to reinforce it um and
uh you're playing this sniffing dog
who's like basically a police dog and uh
so you're sniffing for people that are
eating un-american food it takes place
in a
future that wasn't really very
futuristic to be honest um
and
the idea would be that if you smelled
someone smelled the the wrong kind of
food then you would bark and um
basically would send a swat team down to
like to uh
address the issue of someone eating
so-called un-american food and of course
the joke is that like none of it was
un-american food um there were but the
the way it worked is that this device um
you can kind of see it it's uh
in the corner the like
wooden
uh device with the four holes
um
was made by some students of mine uh in
montreal and it's called the death with
3000 they made it for a zombie game
and it plugs into uh your software and
it runs on uh you know arduino and um it
can send out one of four different
smells and we used that and i literally
like took different kinds of food and
put them inside of the the device and
when you
went in this game when you went up to a
person that was you know sitting in the
park just minding their own business
it would
blow out air over one of these uh
containers of food and if you you'd
smell it you could identify you know was
it a hamburger which is like in this
uh dystopian world like the only
approved
food um or was it something else and uh
so so yeah that was one of the more
recent
uh incursions into trying to make the
sense of smell
uh
meaningful and uh not just a sort of um
mood setting
uh
sense
uh so then the pandemic so that was like
right before the pandemic um the
pandemic obviously hard on on everyone
um uh
i went to remote teaching like many and
like many of you all might have gone to
remote learning if you were
already in school at that point and uh
it was also just
very hard on people physiologically
psychologically um
and still is you know
and thinking about what could i do to
try to
share what i know about how human
physiology is
works and is
maybe help people that might have a need
to
feel even a little bit better because
like we were all stuck in our homes by
ourselves
a lot of events got cancelled and
you know
helping people by sharing even a little
bit of what i was learning at that point
about somatics which is one of my areas
of interest
i wanted to make some kind of of a
presentation about that so i developed
this you could call it a game or you
could call it a um
[Music]
performance really uh called protection
song and the way i i structured it was a
kind of text
not a text adventure but a
text
experience in the game making software
twine has anybody heard of twine before
um it's like a narrative
um
you know interactive narrative
software that's really simple to use and
really accessible
and i made a story that you can
experience through twine or
experience through audio performance
audio
about essentially being a small uh
prehistoric mammal which is what we see
here in the picture um named ayo maya
um
and uh
it was taking people through an
experience of being an early mammal like
where did we get this sensorium that we
have of you know these horrible things
are happening and we just kind of shut
down and we go into like fight or flight
mode or
um you know how did we get to be the way
we are because a lot of people were kind
of blaming themselves for for the way
that their you know feelings the way
they were reacting to the situation and
i kind of wanted to make the point that
no this is like how we as humans and as
mammals essentially have been
um
developed you know socially and
physiologically for the the way that we
are reacting to this it's totally normal
that people are
shutting down or you know
changes in their in eating or things
like that and i also wanted to kind of
through the process of telling the story
bring people back to their senses so
there's there's elements of this
presentation that actually are
interactive with people needing to like
have a little piece of a snack and a
drink of water
and doing some breathing exercises and
it really gradually takes you through
all these things while telling you the
story of
how these early mammals responded to
their world and that was
just felt like something i could bring
even though everyone's stuck on on zoom
and watching things on on youtube so
um yeah
so
getting up to current day that was you
know a bit of a of a fast run through
through my um
how am i doing for time it's like 11 30
okay
yeah um
and you
know obviously it's no surprise to
anyone that we've really got a crisis on
our hands i especially know that people
of you know your generation are
extremely affected by this and um i'm
myself i'm generation x so
um
you know i feel so strongly for people
that that are
having to deal with this when it isn't a
problem they made and that being you
and uh you know it it
i
it's hard to figure out what to do and
and like okay here we find ourselves
like so many things that we took for
granted we are not able to take them for
granted anymore and doing so is is
hurting other people so
how do we handle that knowledge
and everyone's going to bring to that
question what they have you know to give
and in my case i'm a game designer as
you've seen
and uh trying to think about how
what i do is actually going to make uh
any kind of dent in in that like the
because there's you know all the like
in information that's overwhelming and
uh the inertia you know the state of uh
economic
reality and you know try to help
myself as well as other people not not
lose hope in the sight of all those
things
um
and you know people do say that games
are are good at certain things like they
are better than other kinds of media
like maybe linear
um media at you know
modeling systems helping people
understand what's going on uh in a
complex uh
scenario
um or
helping people give people an experience
like they actually feel like they're
living it themselves and they feel it
very personally when when they play a
game
um it also creates identity so many
people form uh you know a deep
connection with worlds and characters
and
take that outside of the game as well
and they also i'm sure everyone here
plays games with friends and games are
really good at creating community so it
seems really like that there are ways in
which games could make a meaningful
difference in the kinds of things we
need to know to do
to
address what's going on
climate-wise
and in fact there are a number of
organizations and entities that are
making steps into this and it's been
happening you know it's been increasing
over the last few years
just to name a few uh one that is maybe
quite
prominent right now is the the igda
which is our it stands for international
game developers association so that's
our professional organization
has a special interest group on climate
and they're doing a lot of uh and it's
all volunteer work but they're doing
work to try to
think of what are the techniques that
games in particular can use to fight uh
climate change and they have recently
released a playbook
and they're also working on getting like
uh the research behind all of these
things very clearly documented
there have been a lot of game jams um
again like a game jam being everyone
sort of simultaneously working on a kind
of thematic issue and in this case they
were doing a climate game jam and uh
released a number of different people
that were working in this jam released a
number of different games recently
and there have been a few different ones
that's you know games for change is one
of the bigger organizations for uh
transformational or meaningful games in
our
space and they've been organizing those
as well as other groups have there are
like other media like there's an entire
podcast that's just about how can game
developers fight climate change called
doing our bit
um so i want to mention that
and you know the game companies are
starting to see how important it is too
hopefully it's not entirely greenwashing
uh you know it depends probably on the
company and um
one that has been uh making
plenty of efforts is unity which you may
all know from the unity game engine
and so they've been doing uh different
funding different initiatives and events
and and trying to make progress on this
and there's a growing body of of written
literature and uh of like compiled lists
of games that have climate uh themes and
a lot of effort for us to try to
understand
what everyone else is doing and learn
best practices from that
um and for me personally okay i don't
want to give any spoilers and you know
how many people have seen everything
everywhere all at once anybody a few
okay
i'll try not to spoil it too too badly
it's it's such a beautiful movie
um and i just saw it actually a few days
ago while i was you know in the midst of
writing this and i was like yes that's
exactly it i don't know why i didn't you
know from the first time i saw it i
didn't remember it but
um in this particular scene the main
character evelyn is putting a googly eye
on her on herself you know and um that
might seem really ridiculous and it kind
of is but that's that's pretty much the
point that the movie is making at that
point
um her husband weymond uh is someone who
kind of faces the world with playfulness
and joy and um
kindness and in the course of the movie
she is sort of starting to understand
why he does the things he the way he
does
and and you know in this scene weymouth
asks like what are you doing and she
says learning to fight like you
and for me there there's a scene after
that that i won't describe but it just
kind of
shows her
fighting but also giving people what
they want it's like her fighting is
actually providing joy providing
satisfaction to people in all these
different individualistic ways and
so
for me that was really a captured it
because that's kind of like what i want
to do like it'd be too easy for
thinking about how games are going to
fight climate change to get down a path
of being really doomer and
you know i don't want to be doomer
but i want to be realistic but not too
serious you know
um and so if there's
if we don't enjoy what we're doing and
if people don't enjoy playing it and if
we don't actually enjoy the future then
what are we here for so that's you know
joy and pleasure are an integral part of
survival and that's when it kind of
dawned on me that this is like my my
role to play is
um
play is is pretty much a rhetorical
strategy right it's um
you know it generates kind of
open-hearted interest in things it it
makes people uh lower their guard a bit
and be more engaged
people can be more more curious or are
vulnerable
and
in addition to that creating play
learning to design play
creates deeper engagement and
understanding
of issues as well
so um there's a lot of researchers that
are working on why play works the way it
does and
you all might yourself be working on why
interface has an effect on on someone um
positively or negatively
and
at
cmu at the hci there are a lot of folks
working on thinking about also like what
are the behavioral effects of people
actually enjoying themselves like being
happy um
jess hammer is maybe the one who is most
prominent in that and then others that
are working along with her oh and since
it isn't really obvious
um this is from a kind of not a game jam
but a um i was prototyping a game that
actually taught people how to tie
different knots like like nautical or
other kinds of knots and could they do
that collaboratively
and while i was at a games for change
change festival in australia a few years
back um i just prototyped that one
interaction to see how how people picked
up on that and i'm thinking i'm actually
re resuscitating that one i haven't done
anything with it since then but but i'm
gotten inspired by this finding these
pictures and talking to myself about
these issues to perhaps
pick that up again
um yeah and you know play gets people
actually move and to go out in the world
and do things and uh it's one of the few
media that actually you know part of
fulfilling and participating and
experiencing the work is that you can
actually go and physically do a thing
you're
not passive at all
um and uh
so i you know that is a really important
thing if you're trying to actually get
people to act on uh their environmental
beliefs and so i think
um
this is something that that i want to
bring into the work in this particular
space the example i have here is called
the dance singularity
and um
it was event that uh kokoromi did where
um a little bit hard to see but there is
a
square dance mat uh dance floor
made of nine ddr dance pads so like a
you know three by three
and um each one of those three by three
uh dance squares um
is linked to the the display you see on
the screen there
but it's also linked to a kind of vj
setup so off to the left there are on
the stage you can see me i'm like
controlling the vj thing and the idea
was if we can get everyone to dance as
you know um much or as good or you know
as
uh excitedly as they can that perhaps we
can achieve the dance singularity and
the idea was that when you know there
was the drop in the music it would make
this kind of like explosion in the
graphics but meanwhile the audience is
like you know there is already that
natural thing when you're at a dancing
that people get more excited as you get
close to the rising tension and the
music then like the drop kind of like is
the you know happy explosion um we were
just playing with that and making it
also a thing where there seemed to be
seem to be
a literal connection between what the
dancers were doing and achieving this
kind of like
um you know catapulting into a new
reality
um so you know the
making
something like this making interaction
actually pleasurable is uh the thing
that you know
i think
i want to take from projects like this
like making activism
playful um so
the
the way that we've been doing some work
so far at uh cmu is like pulling
together the research on the impact of
like creating games and how that
actually changes uh people's beliefs and
um the thing things that happened just
really recently
um working on a with a grant from unity
on a
green game design pedagogy so working on
how we can use teaching game design
through making
games that are
expressing things about you know the
environment or about
nature
and also taking some time to look at the
the psychological and sociological
research behind these uh behind what
makes green games work so we can
actually say is this worth it you know
um and then on the right uh
next semester i'll have a team of
students that that actually
they developed their concept uh
independently to create a game
um
that's a echotopia okaytopia how does it
how do we live in an in the future after
things have changed but through the fact
that we have
come together as a you know humanity to
deal with the problems not necessarily
fix them but maybe some of them
fixed and then some having to just kind
of live with
and tying that into the um
some i guess three or so
of the un's sustainable development
goals which is what those those three
icons represent
and they're focusing on things like
localized production and renewable
energy and things like that and
developing a game prototype this next
semester
um okay almost to the end of the time um
yeah so
this is this it kind of wraps up what
i'm looking at games doing and the way i
think of it is a game design for an
exuberant future and the important thing
is that it's making things that we do
together as as a community um in the
research uh i
was looking at i really um
following a lot of the work of adrienne
marie brown you might have heard of a
activist who wrote the book pleasure
activism
and
i really appreciated the
um
thought that she had in an interview
recently
um and i'll just read you a quote from
her it's like the work of changing the
world has a million front lines it's
lifelong work growing your own soul
and i think the most radical way to
approach it is to cultivate collective
agency she says
learn to transform your behaviors
learn as a collective how to transform
our behaviors
and
and
my thoughts personally is that games and
game design are some of the most
powerful ways we we have to do that
thanks
[Applause]
okay does anybody have questions either
on zoom or
otherwise i do okay
um
you were talking about like the smell
again yeah um and i realized that
there's not a lot of
that it's yeah there's not a lot of
games that talks about spell no uh is
there any future progression on that
game itself or do you know anything
about that in the industry because i
feel like
uh the industry has utilized
all types of sensors except for smell
and
it's a difficult one to tackle but it is
the one that's more
sensorial
with vision as well as beautiful right
yeah so what are your possibilities
right so the question is um
how are there other games that work with
smell and and how widespread is it or
how possible is it that's a huge
question i did spend
a lot of time on some other projects as
well and like really digging into what
smell could do
there have been in the past
various points um attempts to make sort
of off-the-shelf things that could be
used in the home as a like device next
to the computer
um
and as you might imagine most of them
were really uh
underwhelming you know part of it is
that it is chemically based so
the
actually getting the materials you need
and getting them into a device that can
then distribute them
um usually limits people uh you know
it's not an economically viable
thing to do in most cases for an
off-the-shelf in the home type thing it
is way more common in things like
experience design like a theme park or
retailing or things like that
um and the other thing is that those uh
smell
components that go into a device would
have a shelf life so they don't last you
know they could decompose or they're
made out of something that's so
artificial that they just kind of smell
bad and
then there's the fact that people have
different associations with different
smells and it's not always that you know
a good smell smells good sometimes my
people develop memory uh it's obviously
known to have strong associations with
memory but people maybe you know like
maybe uh they smell roses but it makes
it makes us think of somebody that was
really mean that wore rose perfume and
you know like it it doesn't mean there's
never a one-to-one um
mapping of smell to you know to and
because it has such a visceral reaction
for people that's important obviously
that's true of everything and then some
people are allergic to certain chemicals
and certain smells and like i i i gave a
whole talk um i could go on and on i
love talking about it
the other project i did with smell was a
little more
a little more simplistic but fun was
called sugar and in that you play a
performing horse
and
there were different smells that would
be delivered based on your performance
in the uh it's basically a stadium
and
if you were doing well then you would
get a very sweet sugary smell
kind of middling was you'd get a grassy
sort of smell
and when the horses uh messed up their
performances they would poop and then
there was a poop smell that i made out
of horse poop so
it
didn't smell that bad actually it sounds
like gross but it wasn't it wasn't as
bad as it sounds but i like horses so
um
yeah so and i've taught classes where
i've had students working to try to
experiment further with with making
meaningful
interactions with smell it's very tough
um it's fun it's so fun
but it's really complicated so there i
think that's the main reason like those
are some of the main reasons why it
hasn't been more more common
a physical or analog product and that's
it
that that is probably the best use case
yes
okay
we have two questions on zoom okay the
first one is from
we are unmuted
hello can you guys hear me yes
well
yes we can hear you yes we hear you
repeat all right i couldn't hear you say
yes beard um hi i also have a question
about the smell study that you did with
being a dog and i was curious if you
could speak to or if you think that
there are any um ethical concerns or the
reinforcement of bias opinions by
putting people in a game that's supposed
to be the near future and then like
awards points by arresting people for
not eating hamburgers that are dubbed as
like the only american food in the game
um
yeah i would say there are ethical
concerns that's uh you know something
after making the satirical game we
realized that not everyone would
understand what it meant so i wouldn't
call it research though it was a piece
of art so there are slightly different
constraints about what it can or should
do
but uh yeah i feel like what i learned
from that is you know like they're
not everyone is going to receive it in
the same way it's it's clearly could be
very troubling so even though a lot of
satirical artwork is you know it's when
you're working in that territory uh it's
like how do you communicate best that
something
isn't promoting the thing that it's
satirizing and i'm not sure i know the
answer to that you know putting
warnings on things or other ways of
contextualizing it or having
you know in the for instance in the
other thing i did with the um
being a
a prehistoric mammal you know there's
some scenes in that which are could be
scary and even for that which was a
later work i put in like a pre-care
document and an aftercare document
and so i think if i were to go back and
do something again like the the
guilty smells that i would be
a lot more careful to try to
address what the obvious you know
possible issues are around around the
like violence that was deployed depicted
in that particular piece
thank you
um
our second question is from
you
how you can am i audible
yes
yes we hear you oh cool um yeah i i just
wanted to ask um
there are a lot of these uh movements in
green games as you've mentioned uh have
there been any kind of key performance
indicators or like examples where you
know aha we've done it we've we've made
a dent in the world as you say and
kind of um if there are well what are
the like most impactful ones do you see
i don't know the answer yet and one
thing that
is happening
right now is a literature review so
there are uh
researchers
at uh cmu in the hci
that are
doing that exact thing they'll be
working on it this summer to try to see
what we can find and then see where the
the gaps are to try to address some of
that
so that's the short answer is that
probably there are some uh it
you know people are working to pull that
together to make that a resource
i'm coming personally from uh more the
practitioner space and
so i'm not directly involved in that
research but i'm collaborating with the
folks that are doing that
can i ask a quick follow-up on that one
um because i'm very curious about
how are you setting up the the goals for
the green games are you thinking about
changing people's attitudes clarifying
disinformation trying to
get them to change behaviors right um
all of those things could be possible i
think it's you know a case-by-case basis
there are there is some really good um
literature on
the
four practitioners for developed game
developers that want to make change
through games one is called the
transformational design framework by
sabrina solba
there are others that are also
attempting to
you know put into
actionable form
how to do
you know create a
change in perspective or
a change in knowledge even just
determining what kind of change you want
to make you know and then
helping so
um yeah it's
there's maybe not entirely separate
literatures for those who are are
researching
uh you know and using
you know
more
methodological
rigor and those who are trying to see
how can we actually use that like i want
to make a thing and i
uh you know how do i actually implement
that
so
there is some crossover
but right now is like a very fertile
field in case anyone's interested in
researching that now would be a really
good time to
to figure out a good question that you
could tackle
i see one back there oh great thank you
for your presentation um
i was wondering so we've been working on
a lot of different projects and
it seems like all your research projects
or game ideas
are at the intersection of a lot of
different fields and i was wondering
so my question is twofold i guess is
first how would you come up with these
ideas
and second when you have these ideas how
do you start i mean how do you learn
about these
these different fields
and how do you collaborate with other
people
um it's different for everyone okay
that's
always an interesting question when i
hear other people get asked that
often for me it's
it's kind of like a there's a venn
diagram in my head of like seeing that
there's
some things that i know about uh that
i think it's obvious that they overlap
and that they're related or that there
could be something interesting
in that intersection but nobody seems to
be doing it and i'm like well i guess
it's going to have to be me
that's how a lot of those things happen
and then you know in terms of things
like the the smell or like
proprioception and dancing and stuff
like that i'm kind of a hedonist so like
things that i want to participate in
like i don't know singing or
um you know eating food or stuff like
that i'm always trying to figure out how
can i make my practice actually
make that a thing that's more likely for
me to get to do and help other people do
as well
so i'd say that's maybe where they come
from and then do you have a second part
to your question that i missed
yeah how do you learn about these these
fields
and you collaborate with other people
yeah i'd say i'm a pretty voracious
learner and um
i am not afraid to walk up to a random
person who
might and it's usually not walk up to
it's usually send a very very
elaborately written email to
um a person who's doing something that
seems interesting and many people of
course would love to talk about
their work to people who are excited
about it and of course sometimes just
saying the word games gets people inside
interested and opens doors
um
so that's how i've mainly done that and
also just kind of putting out there what
my interests are
the project i was mentioning with
theresa devine happened because i was
really interested in
you know somatics and movement and
motion and
how those relate to disability um but
looking at it from a very different
perspective and i happened to mention
that in a talk like this at the end i
was like and here's the stuff i like to
do
and you know she was there my talk and
she just raised her hand much like you
are sitting here now is like do you want
to collaborate on that and i'm like yes
so so that's that's kind of how those
things happen is is by you know putting
it out there putting out a tweet if if
that's what you do or you know whatever
the way you reach out um and then
um you know being unafraid to talk to
people but also respecting their time so
you know not not
going uh
not taking up more than some of
someone's energy than than is fair for
to expect them to give so that would be
how i would manage it
yeah um i i was wondering because you
kind of talk about games in
slightly two ways for me like
um you're thinking about like the
impacts of the game um
and what kind of emotions or behavior it
might like instill in people but then at
the same time
um there's like 3u game is also art
um and i wonder if like because i think
for the
dog sniffing game i feel like there was
like a a
an opposition between those two things
because you're trying to
be able to like make your art but at the
same time
you're facing you know reports about uh
how people are impacted by this game so
i was wondering like how do you
especially when designing
um serious games like how do you
reconcile those two things wow yeah
that's a tough one how and the question
is how do i reconcile
maybe do i reconcile
my uh
interest in games having an impact and
games being a free expression of like an
artistic um
you know or critical perhaps um or other
kinds of artistic expressions
usually it
um
depends it's
broken down a little bit by which
project it is some of them are more
intentionally intended to be
games that have an effect and others
it's not as clear that i'm making a
you know a transformational game
um i think maybe that's
you've kind of put you know hit the nail
on the head because i think like part of
what i'm saying
to myself
today
is that it
i i don't want to make transformational
games that don't
also have some feeling of
uh
you know joy or um that don't
maybe
um
seem
not magical but just i want them to have
to people have feelings other than oh
yeah i just learned about the polar
bears you know like i wanted to actually
feel like
they're in a narrative or they're in a
world
and then have that also somehow reach
them
uh either intellectually or or
in action because that's like the best
art does that right we it's it's maybe
not as studied and we're not we're not
um
holding art to
specific requirements in terms of the
way it leads you to behave in a certain
way but
that art will do that it'll make you
feel things and then out of those
feelings you may take actions and
so i think for my practice
i'd like those to be more
combined
than they currently are
is that answered somewhat
um
i don't know how much more time we have
but there's over here yeah that we have
one more minute but i bet that
we could get one more question in so i
i'm wondering like for climate change
specifically is a problem like there's
this big asymmetry between people in the
developed world who are producing more
emissions and people in the developing
world who will probably bear the brunt
of the impacts i'm wondering how you
think about that when you're choosing
uh how to intervene with games and like
what what the goals of the games are
because it seems like most of the
projects are targeting people in like
north america in the developed world
well those are definitely the ones who
are causing most of the issues and
therefore it's very valid to target uh
the um
developed world
um i think so far and i can only speak
to what i've done so far
um with you know in the for instance in
the in the class i was uh talking about
developing for this next fall um it some
of the the photo that was there was
actually based on
uh an assignment in the intro to game
design class that i just taught and the
way we
you know worked on the climate topic is
by involving local meeting pittsburgh
uh ecological and environmental
organizations so it was hyper local it
wasn't even just like oh let's talk
about north america or you know
pennsylvania or whatever it was like
really like and that's where people have
the most capacity to act and um so that
seemed like a reasonable thing and also
because we're really excited that the
people in those groups might want to
you know
take that what we made and actually use
it somehow and some of them are
so
yeah and i think though maybe to your
point
what
is important to me is that not every
thing in this space is actually on a
screen there needs to be things that
don't rely on certain forms of
technological you know
excess or you know privilege
there have to be ways to
get the the games more widely
distributed
and um but i i totally think that that
tackling people who are
in a position to make a bigger impact on
you know the change
um by changing not only what they do
personally but what their governments do
is is you know
very important so
yeah
well our time is up and please uh join
me thanking our guest today